all right I want to talk next about the
things that different people are doing
in response to what's going on with the
coronavirus pandemic there are people
who uh in their place of business if
they control if they have a place of
business and they have control over what
goes on there
are saying my employees need to be
vaccinated or my customers need to be
vaccinated or you need a negative test
if you're not vaccinated or whatever one
Alabama doctor is now saying he is not
going to treat
unvaccinated people he will not see
unvaccinated patients in his office Dr
Jason Valentine is a physician at
mobiles Diagnostic and medical clinic
infirmary Health posted a photo on his
Facebook page so showing him next to a
sign that says effective October 1st
2021 Dr Valentine will no longer see
patients that are not vaccinated against
covid-19 since posting the sign
Valentine wrote three unvaccinated
patients asked where they could get a
vaccine no conspiracy theories no
excuses just where do they go Valentine
had a blunt answer from those who asked
him about his decision if they asked why
I told them covet is a miserable way to
die and I can't watch them die like that
Valentine said he's currently in the
process of mailing a letter to patients
about his decision he posted a copy of
the letter online we do not yet have any
great treatments for severe disease he
wrote
but we do have great prevention with
vaccines unfortunately many have
declined to take the vaccine and some
end up severely ill or dead I cannot and
will not force anyone to take the
vaccine but I also cannot continue to
watch my patients suffer and die from an
eminently preventable disease therefore
as of October 1st I will no longer see
patients that have not been vaccinated
against covid-19 if you wish to keep me
as your physician documentation of your
vaccination will suffice if you wish to
choose another physician we will be
happy to transfer your records now a
bunch of people wrote to me about the
story and said isn't this a violation of
the Hippocratic Oath don't doctors have
a duty to treat those who are in need of
treatment and the answer is yes but this
is not an emergency physician this is
someone who this is primary care this is
someone who's saying in my office my
roster of patience will not include
unvaccinated people
and this is not emergency medicine this
is not a doctor having someone showing
up and needing to be put on a ventilator
in an emergency room and he says now I'm
going to look away I'm not going to
provide you any treatment this is not
emergency medicine this is primary care
uh so it's you know focusing on the
Hippocratic Oath aspect of this is not
an honest assessment of the situation
what we do need to be thinking about
here is that there is a burden that is
larger than it needs to be being placed
on the medical system being placed on
providers doctors nurses and others and
it is a perfectly reasonable thing to
say wait a second if much of this the
vaccine's not perfect okay you could
still get a case with the vaccine you
could end up in the hospital you could
end up dying even when vaccinated but it
dramatically reduces your odds so if we
have that as a possibility what else can
we be doing doing what else can doctors
be doing to say the burden needs to be
reduced let's find a way to encourage
people to go and get vaccinated now I
took a call on the show a couple of
weeks ago where the viewer actually said
shouldn't when we triage in an emergency
room
take unvaccinated people and triage them
lower priority than vaccinated people so
that we don't say to the person who got
into a car accident your treatment will
be delayed because of unvaccinated
people and my answer was no I don't see
any way that you do that legally I don't
see any way that you do that morally or
ethically from the standpoint of when
you're in an emergency room situation
you're triaging based on severity and
other factors
um and I I don't think that that would
make sense but increasingly if primary
care doctors want to say Hey listen at
my office if you want to be under my
care under primary care if you want to
come in because you might have a sinus
infection or you have you know headache
or you have whatever reason people go
into Primary Care you need to be
vaccinated because I need to reduce the
burden
um then that is something that they can
do and and many doctors could could do
this and ultimately people are going to
have to make a decision do I want to
have a primary care doctor
um and get the vaccine or do I want to
remain unvaccinated and maybe be unable
to find one now of course most primary
care doctors are not going to do this so
it's really academic to say what if
every Primary Care doc did this but good
for this doctor this doctor is doing
something to try to encourage people to
get vaccinated at least three of his
patients have said I'm gonna go and do
it because I want to remain under your
care send me your thoughts about this as
well as other ways that the medical
community could encourage people to go
and get vaccinated you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman we will be speaking
very soon about our upcoming 1 billion
views on YouTube Milestone it's an
insane milestone for a show like ours
more on that upcoming one of the best
ways that you can support what we do at
the David packman show is supporting
some of our awesome sponsors today one
of those awesome sponsors is sheath
underwear a lot of us know all too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional underwear
especially this time of year as the
weather is getting warm sheath underwear
have created unique boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays separate comfortable
dry and cool no more sweatiness no more
chafing no more readjusting it's a
lifesaver sheath underwear is giving the
David Pacman show audience 20 off when
you go to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the promo code Pac-Man give sheath
underwear a shot I've had a great
experience I believe you will too you
can find the link underneath this video
and don't forget to use promo code
Pacman for 20 off